well as promised yesterday during the
five headlines I want to spend a little
bit of time elaborating on a point that
came up during that segment and for that
I want you to imagine a scenario that in
light of recent events you'd think would
generate some attention among the
national news media so picture a black
student walking to the front of a study
lounge at a major university and loudly
announcing that there are too many Jews
in the
room the study lounge isn't a place for
the Jews the student explains they
should leave
immediately and then there's a round of
applause from other non-jews in the room
as the Jewish students make their exit
now if something like that happened how
many Congressional hearings do you think
would be held how many impassioned
monologues will we see on CNN declaring
that bigotry on college campuses has
simply gone too far how many University
administrators would be forced to
resign probably a
few and honestly we don't know the
answers to those questions for sure
because as of now despite the widely
reported outbreak of anti-Semitism on
college campuses this particular
scenario hasn't unfolded as of yet but
if you replace Jews with white people
then we do have the answer to those
questions clear as day that's because a
few years ago at the University of
Virginia a black student did exactly
what I just described she stood up and
she stood up and told white people to
get out of the student center and she
said because of their skin color that
these white students were not allowed
there and indeed some white people got
up and left and it was all recorded on a
cell phone let's watch that
again public service
announcement excuse me if y'all didn't
know this is the MSC and frankly there's
just too many white people in here and
this is a space for people of color so
just be really cognizant of the space
that you're taking up because it does
make some of us poc's uncomfortable when
we see too many white people in here
it's only been open for 4 days and
frankly there's the whole university for
a lot of y'all to be at and there's very
few spaces for us so keep that in mind
thank
you so somebody films that racist
anti-white rant nobody says anything no
one laughs at this racist or condemns
her in any way it's just silently filmed
because everyone's too afraid to
challenge this and the only reaction is
Applause as the white people make their
exit now after this incident it goes
about saying there were no Congressional
hearings no administrators at UA were
forced to resign nobody was even calling
for that there were no Prime Time CNN
monologues about what's wrong with
American
universities as upsetting as it may be
we shouldn't be surprised by that
non-response because systemic anti-white
racism on college campuses is open and
blatant the specifics are rarely
discussed but they're not hard to find
and it's been going on for decades you
know I I vividly remember all the way
back um in 2007 when it was revealed
that the University of Delaware was
running a mandatory re-education program
that forced thousands of students living
on campus to affirm that all whites are
raised racist and that non-whites can't
be racist among other
things and Ras in the dorms were put in
charge of monitoring students and
Reporting any of them who harbored
unapproved opinions on race or sexuality
or related topics the university system
the university University of Delaware
rather they referred to these struggle
sessions as treatment for white
people and when the Free Speech group
fire brought all this to light the
university hastily shut the program down
but nothing changed in the University
system because nobody forced any kind of
change those kinds of things continue to
happen they've been happening ever
sense even on University of Delaware
they were just
repackaged there was no moral Panic
about the scourge of anti-white racism
on college campuses instead in the years
since that episode and for a while
before it the university system
continued to impose a radical anti-white
anti-christian anti-truth Doctrine on
millions of students Nationwide
literally millions of college students
have been taught and many have come to
believe that white people are inherently
bigoted and evil along with all manner
of other Insidious left-wing myths like
that whole thing about how men can give
birth and women can have
penises and that's why the the current
burst of outrage over anti-Semitism on
college campuses it's more than a little
bit
conspicuous people in corporate media
and even some prominent figures in
Democrat Party are finally speaking out
against discrimination in the University
system but the years and years and years
years and years and years of rampant
anti-white ISM including the mandatory
brainwashing sessions where whites were
told to hate themselves for their skin
color never garnered an ounce of outrage
from these people right from the
corporate media the Democrat from the
mainstream there are plenty of
conservatives who spoke out against it
I've got a Christmas gift idea that's
sure to make you the hero of the season
now we all know the holidays can be a
bit hectic the shopping the cooking the
never- ending list of things to do but
fear not because I've discovered a gift
that's not thoughtful it's downright
transformative the gift of genell
skincare from now until Christmas
genell's most popular package has a
special discount just for my listeners
at genucell.com Walsh treat yourself and
your loved ones to the absolute best
skincare in the world those troubling
forehead wrinkles fine Lin skin redness
and yes even a sagging jawline will
disappear right before your eyes with
genus cell's most popular collection
genus cell promises immediate effects
you'll see results in less than 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back plus
included in every most popular package
is your free hyaluronic a serum for skin
hydration to restore your youthful
appearance Janell sent down a ton of
products for the entire office and I
can't even put into words how much
better their faces look because of genus
cell everybody discusted me just a
little bit less now it's like Christmas
came early you deserve to look and feel
your best this holiday season go to
jus.com Walsh to get this incredible
holiday discount every order today is
instantly upgraded to free express
shipping that's genucell.com
Walsh today Grand Canyon University is
an affordable private Christian
University based in Phoenix Arizona they
are dedicated to making education fit
into your already busy schedule which is
why they offer 270 of their academic
programs online from scholarship to
academic support gcu's graduation team
provides you with personal support you
need to obtain your goals gcu's online
programs offer you the freedom to earn
your degree on your own time from
wherever you are GCU is praised for its
culture of community giving and impact
they integrate the free market system
and a welcoming Christian worldview into
their academic programs achieve your
goalss with a personalized plan and a
supportive team behind you find your
purpose at Grand Canyon University
private Christian affordable visit
gcu.edu that's
gcu.edu the university system as a whole
has been up until now mostly exempt from
criticism by the corporate media and its
ideological
allies now that has changed in the last
like five minutes yesterday we played a
clip of the fared zaharia Zachariah
whatever it was monologue on CNN uh
blast Cas in the University system for
its political and ideological bias and
many conservatives have celebrated that
monologue as we talked about and you
know they celebrated other similar
glimmers of Sanity from the corporate
media on this issue but there's not much
to celebrate here the criticisms of the
universities are are the safest possible
criticisms to
make they still aren't touching the
third
rail
now all of this is not to say that that
anti-Semitism isn't a problem it is no
serious person can deny
that but the very selective nature of
this accountability tells you that the
people calling out the system today
aren't willing to go down and inspect
the roots of the
problem it also shows that only certain
groups are allowed to be viewed as
victims it kind of reminds me of when um
Nick Cannon went on that rant claiming
that white people are bloodthirsty
Savages and that blacks are the real
Hebrews now he was forced to apologize
for the Hebrews bit because it was
anti-Semitic
which arguably wasn't even anti-semitic
it was just crazy which sometimes those
two things go together not always but
either way the much more aggress
aggressively bigoted and racist stuff
about how white people aren't even human
how they're subhuman Savages that was
glossed over there was no apology for
it this is why I'm kind of glad to see
you know that as we talked about
yesterday Harvard circling the wagons
around claudian gay because maybe it
will show people that the rot in
Academia runs deep
this week as part of his effort to oust
uh claudian gay from Office the Harvard
alumnist Bill Amman highlighted some of
this Rod he published messages that he
received from Anonymous Harvard faculty
members and one faculty member told
Amman quote whiteness at Harvard is
deemed fundamentally oppressive
indigenous people are represented as in
need of justice and reparations Jews are
presented as white people it's therefore
okay to hate Israel and Jews as they are
deemed to be
oppressors you know there kind of
reminds me of someone who made this
connection when everything first
happened with the war in Israel about
you know the reason why the left is
circling around Hamas is because they're
the less white group I think there was
someone who made that point I think it
was actually me more on that in a second
another faculty member explained quote
Israel is the rare case where we have a
a hot conflict between people that are
deemed white versus people of color a
third Professor put it this way quot
it's about whiteness versus people of
color now putting all this together
Amman concluded that uh in his letter to
clog inlay that that quote the problems
uh at Harvard are clearly not just about
Jews in Israel it's abundantly clear
that straight white males are
discriminated against in Recruitment and
advancement at
Harvard now that's a realization that's
been a very long time coming and yet
even now the only members of Harvard's
faculty who are willing to talk about it
are also insisting on
anonymity because they're
afraid even though these professors work
in an academic institution that's
supposed to Value free thought and
dialogue and many and even though many
of these faculty members have tenure
they're too scared to say anything on
the record at one of the world's best
universities supposedly faculty members
have less freedom of speech than a
random person on Twitter and by the way
this is not a whataboutism
argument okay if anything this is a what
is it argument or maybe a where does it
come from argument yes we should be
highly critical of anti-Semitic language
on college campuses but where does it
come from what is it rooted in the
problem is that the current backlash
University system is only surface level
we're not digging deeper to see what the
problem is rooted
in that's also why so many people seem
to be surprised that college campuses
around the country have rallied around
Hamas it's not surprising if you
understand what's actually going
on for most of these college kids as as
I have argued from the beginning they
see the conflict overseas as a conflict
between the colonized and the colonizer
as those University officials themselves
were were saying the colonizer is always
the whiter group in any
dispute the colonized are the less white
it's a simple formula and this ideology
of decolonization it is indeed
genocidal they truly believe that the
colonizers wherever they are and whoever
they are deserve to be killed that's
what they
believe that's the context for this
anti-Semitism issue on campus it's where
it comes from it bubbles up from the
depths of the very rotten core of the
American University
system it's so rotten that cannot be
salvaged it cannot be reformed by
getting rid of a few administrative
officials and it especially cannot be
solved or even really addressed if we're
treating the pramas stuff as if it's
isolated and new and happening in a
vacuum it's a bigger and much deeper
problem and until we face that fact as
long as we're celebrating scraps that
CNN tosses our way then nothing will get
better the claing gays of the world will
keep their jobs and white and Asian men
Al alone among all other groups will
have to fight for theirs that is until
we can all agree that the entire system
which is rotten to its
core is
canceled if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there godp speed